alors bas talent d'imitation ce soir en
plus on à liane foly éco et éco et il
est exceptionnel mutation sèchement tu
m'a impressionné parce que tu as leur
jus parler de lui ce que j écoute à la
radio et j'ai même pas que c'était toi
qui faisait aussi des imitations presse
et moins cher je vois là tu fais des
trucs doux alors on va regarder première
battle c'est parti amer lola marois
vanessa paradis jamais rêve donc tu
effaces lola lola bigard vas-y tous les
taxis data partout on n'a pas commencé
de vanessa paradis s'y attends tu
découvres maintenant qu'elle est conne
[Applaudissements]
je suis très très ému un défi technique
ce soir parce que j'aime mon meilleur
ami 30 ans et alors il n'y a pas mieux
que lui pour faire tous mes sketches
mais qui connaît par coeur c'est bien
aussi que nuit à très très longtemps
voulait pas pourrait conseiller tous les
deux un sommet si tu veux est ce que tu
veux toujours ou pas bien sûr tu veux te
crie conseiller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bastarache titoff gens là bas si
dominique strauss kahn
génial alors ben fils dominique strauss
kahn oui donnez moi la suite toile de
jute pour moi même et un but ce soir là
si j'étais ici vous êtes trouve quand
même on finit fort comme tous ses petits
gier
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr ces tuteurs 5 à 10 isabelle
vitari vocaux et bigard alors la
féminité à saint tropez
c'était c'était beaucoup plus commencer
un duo le voeu du dub était là mais le
problème que je sais jean marie c'est
que on peut dire des trucs avec des
petites touches
ah ouais
mon talent talent qu il t'a pas entendu
j'en aurais fait reconnaît pas besoin de
battles encore gao à pourquoi vous
mettez des imitations alors que savait
qu'il est nul l'amour la drogue fait pas
partie mutation par ressemblances et les
boudeurs nicolas bonjour mes chers
français suez cher française on a dit
sarkozy
moi je fais très bien à karim wade c'est
du sérieux
[Applaudissements]
moi de lui
ben ali que chacun fasse sa meilleure
imitation bois la meilleure a dit à ce
poste que c'est sarkozy est bien content
et je vais vous dire quelque chose
oui très contente d'avoir secoué
sébastien jeudi pour coup sébastien
cauet c'est quelqu'un qui écoute le soir
à la radio
alors quand même dit pourquoi tu écoutes
ces conneries tu regardes à nina igiv
zone des tang
j'ai besoin de détendre oui madame
chabot j'ai besoin d'étendre ses droits
attention un acteur studio allait passer
mais ça a foutu ça monte d'un mètre à
les interrogations rentrez chez vous
appelez pas cotées rattrapées
c'est la honte de doute on est les
bateaux abattoirs
des dom tom quand les combattre à
quesnoy redisons ce soir je reçois le
mec a piqué ma case qui a piqué tout le
monde
kapikian laurent baffie cyril hanouna
[Applaudissements]
chantale j'aime bien parce qu'on
comprend jamais rien ils s'attendent à
une exit tax and line ou alors qu'est ce
que j'ai dit qu'aux nicolas vague du
négoce qui me plaît c'est qu'il ya
toujours les phrases qui veulent jamais
sur des moments qui partent et des
phrases qui veulent rien dire les
plaisirs way s'il ya toujours ce moment
de cérémonie ce soir dole nrj music
awards on va recevoir un chanteur et
n'oubliez pas que c'est en touchant les
étoiles qu'on devient celui qu'on est
qu'ils vous regardent d'en bas
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est qu'il ya un mec de mon équipe
parce que nous on adore timité ouais je
sais dans l'émission est à chaque fois
pour bibi à chaque fois équité il est là
ou pas il est là il est tant pis
[Applaudissements]
alors il est avec toi la radio ouï
exceptionnel tartas je te dis c'est pas
merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a de la barca prévu voilà je vais
vous le dire mais là tu sais quoi sera
sera développée sous préfet laurent sait
que c'est mon préféré bouder mon préféré
ah voilà aujourd'hui on va faire un truc
de fou vous savez quoi les chéris on va
mettre tout ça malgré dix ans espagnols
[Applaudissements]
c'est là ma guitare je l'avais quittera
les fermiers cabellou sais pas ce que je
fais le pass je sais le faire faire la
langue du sèche alors j'ai joué dans un
film
j'ai joué à me prostituer dans une autre
film parce que c'est vrai que j'ai joué
beaucoup de prostituées notamment dont
trois ou quatre films apparaît que je
fais le kiss-in je fais le fun comme
chez soi c'est beaucoup de choses
peut-être que je fais des choses que je
peux pas dire c'est cela que l'on limite
on me dit que j'ai mis très bien maître
gims apparemment
[Musique]
[Rires]
ça fait pas ces projets c'est bien
c'est pas mal mais c'est tout à après je
sais pas trop mais pas la méchanceté
désert mais le silence des hommes qui
font tous semblant d'exister ouah
[Applaudissements]
et
yes
pas mal
[Applaudissements]